y
[Música]
colombianos
la decisión de haber presentado la
reforma de transformación social
sostenible tiene un único propósito y es
el de dar estabilidad fiscal al país
proteger los programas sociales de los
más vulnerables y generar condiciones de
crecimiento luego de los efectos
arrojados por la pandemia del cob y 19
de acuerdo a lo que le había compartido
al pueblo colombiano el pasado viernes
30 de abril donde le comunique al país
la decisión de construir una nueva
iniciativa a partir de los consensos que
nos permita buscar los recursos
necesarios para pagar los gastos de la
pandemia y garantizar las ayudas
sociales que se requieren les solicito
al congreso de la república el retiro
del proyecto radicado por el ministerio
de hacienda- y tramitar de manera
urgente un nuevo proyecto fruto de los
consensos y así evitar incertidumbre
financiera